انا من المغرب من اكادير والله فرحانين
انا مخم بقطر
والله العظيم الكل منتجين مع بعض والله
الكل مكمل بعد الفريق والجمهور والله
تشجيع الجمهور واللعب بتاع الفريق والله
العظيم واحنا فرحانين بيهم وكثير فرحانين
والله
الاغنيه الرسميه
لقطر 2022 هيا هيا المغرب الى المونديال
او الفينال هيك شيء مش متذكرها بس المنتخب
المغربي يحقق نتيجه للتاريخ انه اول منتخب
عربي يصل لهذه ما حققه الحين والله ما شاء
الله اسود الاطلس كان واسود اليوم في
الميدان وفرحونا تحيا المغرب وتحيا
الجزائر تحيا الدول العربيه
غير ديرونيه انصرنا العالي تعالى هلا هلا
هلا المغرب
هيا هيا هيا انا جاي مصر والله
نسينا جاي مع البحر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عدوينه
هيا هيا هيا الاولى
ان شاء الله الفينال عليكم عوالا هيا هيا
هيا الاولى
ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
وسط الدوحه رونالدو
[موسيقى]
باي باي